I mean look at that Tom Cruise is back
in the mummy and the stunts action
sequences special effects I mean they
all look spectacular here's your first
look at the new and improved take on a
movie classic here we go
does this guy ever get tired Tom runs
jumps and punches his way through
countless scenes but this isn't just an
action movie it's a monster movie -
you're playing a Navy SEAL it's set in
Iraq it's very scary this is a real
monster movie so there's some scenes and
sequences in here that are really epic
and it's people are gonna jump toms
toughest foe The Mummy of course sexy
sofia boutella transforms into a super
creepy creature
the audience can expect to be
excruciatingly leak terrified you
identify with these classic characters
they terrify us and yet you feel
sympathy for them
welcome to Buddhism we've got Russell
Crowe in your film playing doctors
credibility is incredibly we had some
great scenes together and a really great
fight scene between the two of us which
is really was blast doing it's the first
time Tom and Russell have ever teamed up
for a film Russell I've known each other
over 20 years we've talked about working
together now we're gonna do this very
cool fight
I can't wait for an audience to see it
I've always wanted to make a movie like
busy
it's a hell of a lot of fun
[Applause]
you
you